howdy folks maximum McGee here along
with mark Walton from our UK team and
together we're celebrating the release
of the new mortal kombat x AKA Mortal
Kombat ten trailer mark I know you and I
both watch it and enjoyed it many times
over many toys and I think we're gonna
go a couple of rounds a theory fighter
and just try to figure out how much of
this trailer is fact vs absolutely ma'am
so the first thing that I want to dive
into is the look of it the presentation
based on what we saw in the trailer how
much of that do you think is gonna be
how the actual game plays versus just
making it look nice but you know I I'm
gonna go out on a limb here and say I
will use my own face oh no I'm gonna
face I know but I won't use my own face
if that is actual gameplay footage there
is there is no way in my mind that that
is real fun guy I mean something that
struck me as interesting is even if it's
not like 121 exactly how the game's
gonna look and I agree with you I doubt
especially with a lot of those cinematic
mr. Wayne smooth and like you know like
the x-ray moves like when they come
across like then order the lower back
okay in a real game I know we like going
from like a last gem to current gen
stuff but it's just it you know I can't
see it making that big early now see
that smoothness i think is what's
interesting though yeah I'm curious why
if this isn't entirely representative
Ithorian gonna look like why another
room would put so much emphasis on
making it look as smooth as possible and
want to start setting that expectation
people's minds because if you just say
oh there's a new more comic and coming
out you're gonna seem like oh it's gonna
be all herky-jerky robot the jerk a
vision yeah absolutely I know I think
one of the things that they mentioned it
in the press release was that you know
they're trying for this whole like
cinematic feel right and for me it's you
know as a siphon that the gameplay
aspect it's integrating the story that
they had in the game rather than having
separate cutscenes and like bookending
your fights and it's just sort of a bit
felt a bit tacked on in a way now it's
going to be like forming a part of the
fight that's what i'm thinking is sort
of meant by that seamlessness and that's
cinematic less if they're talking about
you know you can see the characters
standing off against each other in like
the trailer they look like they're but
you know they're going to keep me some
of that stuff like that imagine that you
know in spurts in the fight with some
dialogue
and see the happy so in the press
release that i got from Warner Brothers
they did have a note in there about how
they're going to be they're gonna let
players play as multiple versions yeah
same character what do you what do you
think one of others an empire ah that
they'll be different colors okay here's
a costume yet as far as yeah I can see I
don't know man I mean you know it's with
fighting games traditionally when they
say different version of the same
character with the exception of maybe
evil Ryu it means that they've got some
either a skimpy outfit on the less
skimpy at film that's how fighting games
work so you know i'm i'm skeptical if
it's gonna be anything more than that
but the fact that they've mentioned it
feels like a big deal perhaps I mean
ultra street fighter four does have the
addition select option where you can
play as like ryu from the first vanilla
version of the game or the arcade update
or in the ultra version so i know a lot
of people are speculating it could be
something like that but i saw very much
higher version sub 0 to D Sub Zero I got
a little bit more substantial it's a
little bit easier than just some minor
like minor balancing to be having play
that something I think could be
interesting is a in the original mar vs
capcom if he plays Ryu he had special
moves that would transform him and like
giving chins yes sir door Akuma's Musa
it would be kind of neat if they had
like here's a version of scorpion who's
really good in this particular area of a
weaker and others are like here's a
version of sub-zero that's good at
rushing down and here's a version of
sub-zero that's good it you know the
keep away game and the other like split
it up like that they can split up with
like special powers for instance I mean
like you had the x-ray moves from the
original took one of the original more
combat but the last more combat you know
there's give me some new ones I would
assume you know right it's a new game
they're gonna pump some new x-ray moves
you know maybe it'll be like ultra super
speed 54 where you can select different
combos like when you go into the game
and that could be like the mole per
there's an aspect there talking about
something else that was interesting in
that press release was the note about
the it didn't say explicitly it was
going to be always online but it did say
there is a heavy online component that
feeds into the sort of larger online
medic
there's some sort of global content that
can involve all the Mortal Kombat ten
players what could that possibly
materialize the global contest well you
know that's the story line the more
combat isn't it effectively you know so
you know the fact that they're tapping
into that with you know an online aspect
definitely you know could be very very
cool I mean it is most basic I could see
just seemed like Oh north america's got
20 mortal kombat points this week in
europe thought we got five yeah you guys
better get on them you know so many
games have done that you know I'm hoping
that it's going to be something more
substantial you know that seems to
basically laser at the time that was
gonna weigh about she really really cool
but it's been done to death that sort of
thing and I think there's a lot you
could do it would be more combat but
doesn't involve just this country better
yeah we'll see you know I think you
mentioning earlier that you know does
that mean that this is going to be
something that it's gonna be like a
free-to-play right there's a lot of like
Namco Bandai and even killer instinct to
both experimental but a lot of different
applying different types of free-to-play
models yeah their games and I would
imagine if if not killer instinct if
Mortal Kombat it was sort of going this
online heavy route they probably want to
see if they could apply some of that
technology to their game well everyone
loves money right that's right you know
it makes it easier for people to get
into the game like come on absent okay
okay I'm being very cynical I'm being
very cynical there you're right i think
you know free-to-play stuff can be great
and if it's done in the right way and
like you say you know if it's it's
always connected thing I mean if you've
got the base level you got that leader
boards and stuff seeing what your
friends are doing getting all that stuff
in there basics I know it's tough that
it's tough to kind of just get the sort
of the image in my head of how mortal
kombat is really gonna make a compelling
online experience outside of your
beating the crap out of each other
alright folks are there's still one more
out there we don't know about mortal
kombat Tim but I was able to agree a few
more things out of that trailer I've
written it up on a piece on the site be
sure to check that out otherwise mark
and I we're gonna be heading down to e
throughout the area where we're gonna
see some more combat team for ourselves
so you guys be sure to stay tuned to
that and keep it locked to gamespot com
for all the latest on empty
you